[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اصطدمت جهود الرئيس الامريكي
باراك اوباما للحصول على تفويض بضرب
النظام السوري بمعارض عدد كبير من اعضاء
مجلس النواب الامر الذي يثير الكثير من
حول مصير قرار اوباما بتوجيه ضربه لنظام
الاسد نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من
زاويتين ما حجم حظوظ اوباما في الحصول على
تاييد الكونجرس لمقترح بضرب النظام
السوري وما الخيارات التي يمكن ان يلجا
اليها في حال فشله في الحصول على دعم
الكونجرس
هذا باختياره المحض حمل الرئيس الامريكي
باراك اوباما الى الكونجرس مقترحه بتوجيه
ضربه عسكريه الى النظام السوري على خلفيه
استخدامه اسلحه كيميائيه في ريف دمشق
الشهر الماضي الان وفي وقت يواصل فيه وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي جون كيري مساعيه في
اوروبا لحشد تاييد خارجي لهذه الفكره
تواجه جهود اداره اوباما في الداخل تعثرا
واضحا في مجلس النواب يثير التساؤلات حول
مصير قرار اوباما لضرب نظام
الاسد بد الرئيس باراك اوباما وهو يخاطب
الامريكيين متمسكا بما اعلنه الاسبوع
الماضي بصفته القائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه الامريكيه بان على بلاده شن عمليه
عسكريه على النظام السوري مبرراته ان
الهجوم الكيميائي على غوطه دمشق الشهر
الماضي يشكل تهديدا جديا للامن القومي
الامريكي ولامن واستقرار العالم كذلك وفي
سياق محاولته لاقناع الكونغرس اشار او
اوباما الى ان امريكا ستكون اقوى اذا
تحركت مجتمعه وسيكون تحركها اكثر فعاليه
لكن خياراته لتنفيذ ذلك لا تبدو واضحه اذا
لم يوافق الكونغرس على العمليه خاصه وان
الدلائل تشير الى ان الضربه ستكون خارج
مجلس الامن الدولي وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
رحب ببيان الاتحاد الاوروبي الصادر السبت
عقب اجتماعات وزراء خارجيته في ليتوانيا
وحديثهم عن ادله تدين النظام السوري
لاستهدافه المدنيين باسلحه كيميائيه
ومطالبتهم برد قوي وجلي لمنع استخدامه هذه
الاسلحه مستقبلا ترحيب الوزير جاء رغم ان
الوزراء لم يعلنوا تاييده للضربه العسكريه
التي تروج لها امريكا بل استحسنوا تعهد
الرئيس الفرنسي بانتظار تقرير مفتشي الامم
المتحده عن الامر قبل اي تحرك وذكر ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يشدد على الحاجه للتعامل
مع مجمل النزاع السوري من خلال الامم
المتحده ياتي ذلك بعد يوم واحد من صدور
بيان بذات المعنى من 11 دوله شاركت في قمه
العش بروسيا واعلنت ان ذلك النزاع لا يحل
عسكريا ودعت لتسويه سياسيه سلميه من خلال
تطبيق اتفاق جنيف الذي لم يرى النور العام
الماضي ويظل الحديث عن موت نحو 1400 شخص
بالسلاح الكيميائي مرا بكل المقاييس ويظل
ايضا السؤال المتعلق بخيارات الرئيس
الامريكي لتنفيذ الضربه العسكريه على
النظام السوري
مع طريقه تنفيذ الضربه وجدواها خاصه وان
اوباما يشدد على انها ستكون محدوده من حيث
الزمن والنطاق
والهدف معنا في هذه الحلقه من واشنطن
الدكتور شبلي التلحمي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جماعه ميريلاند
وجيمس ك كفانو مدير معهد الراسات الدوليه
بمؤسسه اارج كفانو اهلا بضيفي نبدا بالسيد
كفانو هل هل هل هناك فعلا اشكال الان في
فرص اوباما للفوز بموافقه الكونجرس على
ضربه للنظام
السوري اعتقد نعم كما تعرف ان هنالك لدينا
مجلسين في الكونغرس الامريكي مجلس الشيوخ
الذي نعتقد ان بامكان الرئيس ان يحصل على
ترخيص وتفويض منه من مجلس الشيوخ اما
المجلس النواب لا احد يعتقد ان الرئيس
سيحصل على قرار من هذا المجلس
وكلما طال الوقت اعتقد انه ليس من المحتمل
وسق الاحتمال حصول الرئيس على تفويض من
الكونجرس نعم في هذه الحاله سيد شبله
الحمي هل
الاشكال يتمثل ايضا حتى في النواب
الديمقراطيين داخل مجلس النواب
بدون شك وراينا ذلك حتى في لجنه السياسه
الخارجيه ونرى ذلك من خلال ما نسمعه من
تصريحات وايضا من خلال محادثاتي الشخصيه
وانا اتكلم مع بعض الاعضاء في الكونجرس
ومساعيه هؤلاء الاعضاء هناك تردد بدون شك
حتى على المستوى الديمقراطي وهذا مبني على
اساسين احد الاساسات هو ان هناك رفض شعبي
في الولايات المتحده راي عام حتى الان
يرفض التدخل العسكري ثانيا ليس هناك دعم
دولي واضح وبعد مجموعه دول العش من الواضح
ان ليس هناك اجماع هذا سيصعب كثيرا على
الرئيس بالنسبه للراي العام الدولي سيد
كفانو الراي العام الامريكي عفوا في سبر
اراه لرويترز 56% من الامريكيين يعارضون
الضربه في سبر اراه ل جالوب
51%
تعتقد بان هذه المسائل محدده في تصويت
الاعضاء باعتقادي ان المشكلات الاساسيه
التي يواجهها الرئيس ولم يذكر بشكل واضح
وواقعي خطه عسكريه لم يقدم خطه عسكريه ان
الضربه السريعه التي والمحدده التي تحدد
التي تكلم عنها لم لم تحدث فرقا على الارض
وفي الحقيقه على الرغم من مزاعم الاداره
من
ان تاتي لردع استخدام الاسلحه الكيميائيه
في المستقبل لم تكن هي افضل طريقه للتعبير
عن مصالح الامريكيه اذا ما كانت الاداره
الامريكيه استراتيجيه واضحه لسوريا لربما
لم يكن الوزير كيري وزير الخارجيه يقضي
السته اشهر
الاخيره يبت جهود في حل الصراع العربي
الاسرائيلي ولذلك هنالك الكثير من الت شكك
من ان لهذه الضربه سيكون لها تاثير عملي
يعتقد بشكل كبير ان الرئيس اصدر هذا الخط
الاحمر لانه حس في ذلك الوقت انه لم يكن
ملزما باحترامه واعتقد ان لا اعتقد ان
الرئيس فعلا مهتم بهذا الامر لذلك ان
الراي العام وهو جزء من المشكله المشكله
ان الكونجرس ليس لديه سبب حقيقي لدعم
لاصدار هذا التفويض واذا لم يكن هنالك سبب
حقيقي وعارض الشعب هذا سيكون الرئيس في
موقف صعب جدا اذا في هذه الحاله سيد شبل
الحمي هل وقع الرئيس اوباما في ورطه نصبها
لنفسه اولا بموضوع الخط الاحمر ثانيا
بالعوده الى الكونجرس اصلا في في موضوع لم
يكن مجبرا فيه على
ذلك بالنسبه للنقطه الاولى نعم اعتقد بان
تصريحاته كانت غير مقصو ووقع في فخه بدون
شك ولكن بالنسبه للكونغرس لا اعتقد ان كان
بامكانه ان يذهب الى يتجه اتجاه الحرب ا
بدون عندما يكون هناك رفض شعبي واضح كان
فقط 99% من الشعب الامريكي يوافق ثانيا
بدون البراهين حتى الان من هيئه الامم
ثالثا بدون مجلس الامن في الولايات في في
في الامم المتحده لذلك كان بحاجه الى
الدعم من الكونغرس على الاقل والا لا
يمكنه ان ان يفعل ذلك كان خاسرا لو فعل
ذلك بدون الاتجاه الى الكونغرس فلا اعتقد
ان هذه يعني ا قضيه الفشل في الكونغرس هي
المشكله المشكله هي انه ان حتى الان هذا
الرئيس لم يعرض على الراي العام وعلى
الكونغرس وعلى العالم ما هي المصلحه
القوميه الامريكيه ا التي توجب عليه
بان يقوم بعمليات عسكريه وثانيا اذا كانت
القضيه اخلاقيه وربما وهناك قضيه اخلاقيه
الكل يوافق ان هناك مشكله اخلاقيه كبيره
في في سوريا ولكن اذا كانت القضيه
الاخلاقيه يجب ان يرد عليها عن طريق الحرب
لماذا لا تاخذ امريكا موافقه حتى الحلفاء
في الغرب الذين يشاركونها في القضيه
الاخلاقيه لذلك صعب عليه اقناع الشعب وصعب
عليه اقناع الكونغرس نعم هي القضيه
اخلاقيه بلا شك ولكن ايضا سيد كفانو قضيه
ما اعتبر مصداقيه الولايات المتحده في
التعامل مع المجتمع الدولي ومع اعدائها
لان مثلا ما قاله السيد كيري اليوم قال
الاسد يتابعنا وينظر الينا وكذلك اصدقائه
في ايران وفي كوريا الشماليه وفي حزب الله
عدم الاقدام على ضربه يعني ان الولايات
المتحده ليست في حجم قوه كبرى تستطيع ان
ان ان تغير مجريات الامور في
العالم
هذه خطه سخيفه باعتقادي وفي الحقيقه لا
تعطي الرئيس اي مصداقيه باي طريقه من
الطرق اذا ما قامت الاداره بضربه سيكون
تاثير لما حدث عندما قام الرئيس كلنتن
بهجوم بالهجوم
على على هجوم على مجمع بن لادن اطلق عده
اطلاقات وقال بعد ونج بعد ذك بن لادن وقال
انني نجوت من هذه الضربات واعتقد ان نظام
الاسد سيكون نفس الشيء حيث سينجو من ذلك
ويقول انني مازلت قويا
ودعمه سيدعمه الروس والايرانيون وحزب الله
وسيظل النظام مسيطرا وفي الحقيقه اعتقد ان
الوزير كيري ويقوم بدفع الاداره اجاه نحو
هذا الاتجاه وهو في الحقيقه
يضع يضع تاريخه ويضع منصبه في الخطر اعتقد
ان الوزيره كيري
وايضا استشاري الامن القومي مثل سوزن
رايس لا يعتقدون هم يضغطون على الرئيس
واعتقدوا هو جعل من الكونغرس سبيلا للهروب
حيث يقول ربما سيقول انه لم يكن هذا الامر
خطئي انا لا اعتقد ان الاداره لديها خطه
واضحه للمضي قدما وهم لم يعتق انهم
سيذهبون الى قمه الع وما يزال يجادلون في
هذا الامر لذلك من الواضح ان هذا الامر قد
قد تم جمعه بشكل سريع واعتقد ان الوزير
كري هو الذي يدفع باتجاه التطور في هذا
الموضوع ولكن الوزير كري وكذلك الرئيس
اوباما السيد شبلي تلحمي لم يدخر جهدا في
محاوله توضيح الصوره وكان يقول هذه ليست
لا العراق ولا ليبيا ولا افغانستان ولا
كوسوفو ولا كوسوفو هي ضربه من نوع اخر
ولا قوات بريه ولا امكانيه للتورط في
اطاحه نظام الاسد رغم كل ذلك لم يستطع ان
يكون مقنعا لا اوباما ولا
كيري حسب رايي انا هناك نقطه اهم وهي
بالنسبه
للمصداقيه هناك مشكله في قضيه المصداقيه
المشكله الاولى ان هذه الكلمه اذا نظرنا
اليها من الخارجيه الامريكيه كانت مربوطه
في الخمسينات بما ادى الى فيتنام معنى ذلك
انه بدون تعريف اي خطر على الولايات
المتحده مباشر لا يمكن ان تدافع عن
المصداقيه بحد ذاتها عن طريق الحرب لان في
نهايه الامر قد ت تقوم بعمليه محدوده ثم
ترى انها لا لا النتيجه كانت فاشله ولذلك
بحاجه ان تعمل شيء اخر بعد ذلك للدفاع عن
مصداقيه العمليه الاولى والتصعيد يعني كان
واضح في في فيتنام بدا في في هذه النظريه
وانتهى في في حرب كبيره فهناك تخوف اولا
في هذا الموضوع ثانيا بالنسبه للمصداقيه
اذا نظرنا المصداقيه من الذي سيرى هذه
المصداقيه الشعوب و والحكومات في العالم
العربي لا اعتقد ان احدا في العالم العربي
يعتقد بان اي تدخل الامريكي سياتي سيكون
سببه التدخل لمنع الاسلحه الكيماويه الكل
يعتقد بان الولايات المتحده تعمل لمصالح
اكبر ان كانت تتعلق باسرائيل او بالنفط او
بقضايا استراتيجيه لذلك اذا كان الهدف هو
محدود بالنسبه للاسلحه الكيماويه وال
مصداقيه لا تتعلق في هذا الموضوع كيف من
الممكن ان تكون هذه العمليه قد تؤدي الى
مصداقيه في موضوع الاسلحه الكيماويه هناك
مشكله كبيره كما قلت ذلك اليوم في مقاله
كتبتها في مجله فور فورين بوسي فاعتقد ان
هناك مشكله كبيره بالنسبه للبيت الابيض في
اقناع الراي العام الامريكي وفي اقناع
الكونغرس نعم وهناك مشكله ايضا في الفهم
سيد كفانو عندما عاد اوباما الى الكونجرس
كان الكل يتحدث ان لا مشكله لديه في
الحصول على الكونجرس وكانه ضمن ذلك في
جيبه الان تبدو الامور تنقلب عليه تدريجيا
هل منت تفسير واضح
لذلك في الحقيقه اذا ما رجعنا ونظرنا الى
ان الخطه كانت واضحه لم يكن ينوي الرئيس
ان يطلب من الكونجرس لهذا التفويض وخاصه
عندما قامت الولايات المتحده مثلا باطلاق
عمليتها في ليبيا رئيس لم يطلب تفويضا من
الكونغرس لذلك الخطه كانت فقط ان يقوم بتو
ضربه في نهايه الاسبوع وبعد ذلك يعود
الجميع ولم يحدث شيء سيء ويذهب الرئيس الى
قمه العشر لكن ما حدث ان
البريطانيين في الحقيقه ربما تخلوا عن
الولايات المتحده قبل نهايه الاسبوع تلك
وشعر الرئيس بالضعف وقام الرئيس بنفسه
باخذ القرار بانه بدلا من المخاطر بالتحرك
وحده بل قام بارسال الامر الى الكونغرس
بطريقه لكي يتخلص من هذه المشكله ويجعلها
مشكله الكونجرس في الحقيقه انه مهما كانت
النتيجه من المستحيل للرئيس ان يستعيد
مصداقيته لانه كان هنالك الكثير من
الاخطاء في معالجته للامور افضل نتيجه
ممكنه على الرغم من انه لا توجد نجيده
جيده لكن اعتقد ان الاداره سي في الحقيقه
لن اذا ما قاموا بالحصول على تفويض وقاموا
بضربه محدده ولم يحصل هنالك
اي هجمات انتقاميه ربما سيكونون في موقف
جيد الموقف صعب اذا الولايات المتحده في
ان يدخل في هذه الحرب الاهليه بدون التزام
كبير وكان في الحقيقه الرئيس وغير مهتم
تماما بالقيام بذلك اذا ما سارت الامور في
الكونجرس على عكس ما يريده اوباما ما هي
الخيارات التي يمكن ان تكون لديه في هذه
الحاله هذا ما سنتطرق اليه بعد فاصل نرجو
ان تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نناقش فيها خيارات اوباما في
ضوء ما يبدو تعثرا لجهوده لاقناع النواب
في الكونجرس بتفويضه لضرب النظام السوري
سيد تلحمي برايك ما الذي يمكن ان يفعله
اوباما اذا اذا بالطبع لم يتمكن من الظفر
بموافقه
الكونجرس دعني اجاوب على ذلك من خلال
التعليق على ما قاله زميلي من قبل بان من
الصعب على اوباما استعاده مصداقيته بعد
هذه العمليه ام بالفعل ولكن يجب ان نفرق
بين مصداقيه الرئيس السياسيه ومصداقيه
الولايات المتحده كدوله عظمى هناك فرق
هائل طبعا مصداقيه اوباما السياسيه ضعفت
مهما حصل في الكونغرس ومهما حصل بالنسبه
لسوريا ولكن بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
كدوله عظمى لا اعتقد ان احدا كان يتوقع ما
مهما حصل في سوريا لا احد يتوقع ان
بامكانه القيام بعمليات عسكريه ليست اي
دوله عسكريه محدوده او استعمال اسلحه
نوويه لانه يعرف ماذا سيحصل ليس هناك اي
سؤال عن امكانيه الولايات المتحده و
بالقيام برد لذلك نحن نتكلم عن مصداقيه
سياسيه وفي الكونغرس اذا رفض الكونجرس طلب
الر الرئيس بخوض الحرب في
سوريا اعتقد انه على الرغم من انه يقول
انه له الصلاحيات القانونيه بالقيام بمثل
هذه العمليه بدون موافقه الكونغرس ولكن
سياسيا يكون مستحيل عليه ان يفعل ذلك
اعتقد ان
ا يعني اذا اذا تكلمنا عن مصداقيته
السياسيه وهذه القضيه السوريه الملف
السوري بالنسبه له ملف صغير جدا يعني لم ي
كن يتوقع بان يعالج هذا الملف حاليا هناك
ملفات الاقتصاد والميزانيه والصحه والملف
الايراني امامه ويحتاج الى الكونجرس في كل
هذه الملفات ويحتاج الى مصداقيته في
التعامل مع الكونغرس لا اعتقد بانه
بامكانه ان يخوض حرب معينه حتى محدوده
بدون موافقه الكونغرس هذا صحيح سيد تلحمي
ولكن سيد كفانو كفانو ه هل تعتقد بان في
هذه الحاله قد ق لا يكون الاشكال مع
الداخل الامريكي وانما مع العالم ستبدو
الولايات المتحده كاسد بدون
انياب في الحقيقه اعتقد ان الرئيس سيكون
في موقف صعب جدا اذا لم يحصل على تفويض من
الكونغرس قد
يكون وقد يحصل على ذلك وربما الكونجرس يق
التمويل عنه وهذا امر غير
مرجح بامكانه ان يصدر امرا
تنفيذيا يطلق الضربه لكن اذا ما مثلا ما
الذي سيحدث اذا ما حدثت هنالك عمليات
انتقاميه مثلا ايران قامت بشن هجمات
واغلاق مضيق هرمز وقامت بشن هجمات على
السفرات سيكون الرئيس في موقف صعب جدا
ولكن سيد كرفانه اذا اذا كانت العمليه
خاطفه سريعه ليست وخزه دبوس كما قيل وتقف
معها اوروبا فقد يستطيع اوباما ان يمر من
هذا الامتحان
بسهوله اذا ما كانت العمليه سارت بشكل جيد
ربما
سيستطيع النجاه بذلك سياسيا لكن اذا ما
قلنا اذا ما كانت العمليه ناجحه جدا وبدا
النظام بالانهيار ورايت مثلا صعود القوات
والعسكريه والمسلحين وقوات مثلا المرتبطه
بالقاعده كما راينا في ليبيا
فسيعيش
والوضع على الارض سنت سءل لماذا س ربما
الرئيس سيسعى من توجيه ضربه بدون
تفويض ربما قد يقوم بذلك لكنه هذا الوضع
سيكون خطر بالنسبه له اذا في هذه الح حال
سيد تلحمي اقل ما يمكن ان يوصف
به عمل للولايات المتحده في حال بالطبع
نؤكد في حال رفض الكونغرس ستكون مجازفه
شخصيه سياسيه كبرى من
اوباما بدون شك مجازفه شخصيه ومجازف ايضا
للولايات المتحده لان لا يمكن ان تعرف
النتائج قد تكون قد تكون النتيجه ناجحه
الى حد ما معنى ذ انه ليس هناك رد فعل
سوري لا تغير المعادله تقول الولايات
المتحده فعلت شيئا ونرجع الى ما كنا عليه
ولكن قد يكون هناك تصعيد بدون غير معروف
او غير مفهوم وغير متوقع وحتى لو كان ذلك
محدود اذا قال الاسد ها انا نجحت وهذه
الولايات الم هذه حرب مع الولايات المتحده
ليست حرب مع المعارضه
ا الاتحاد السوفيتي يزيد من دعم
الاسد
ويصعب المعدات التي يعطيها
للاسد كيف يمكن ان يعني تكون النتيجه
ناجحه بالنسبه لاوباما فاعتقد انه في في
وضع صعب سيفشل مهما حصل يعني وضع نفسه في
في وضع صعب ولكن في نفس الوقت عندما تتكلم
عن المصداقيه انا لا اعتقد ان ذلك سيؤثر
على المصداقيه الامريكيه بالنسبه لاستعمال
القوه في المصالح الامريكيه المشكله
بالنسبه للعالم لا احد يهاجم المصالح
الامريكيه مباشره يعرفون ان الولايات
المتحده لها مقدرات ومستعده ان تستعمل
القوه في العالم العربي الكل يقول
الولايات المتحده تفعل كل شيء المصريين
المعارضه تقول
ان الولايات المتحده مسؤوله على ما حصل
والحكومه تقول الولايات المتحده مسؤوله عن
ما حصل ليس هناك افتراض كان في الراي
العالم في الراي العام العربي او الدولي
او او بالنسبه للحكومات ان الولايات
المتحده ليس بمقدرتها التدخل هناك تفسيرات
معينه يكون ذلك طبعا صعب بالنسبه للرئيس
ومصداقيه الرئيس السياسيه ولكن لا اعتقد
ان لذلك ابعاد استراتيجيه على المصالح
الامريكيه ولكن ماذا لو سيد كفانو ماذا لو
استطاع اوباما ان يحصل بالسياسه ما لا
يمكن ان يحصل عليه بالقوه بمعنى انه هذا
الضغط وهذا التجييش
للضربه قد يجعل يعجل ايضا بتسويه ما
بالتعاون مع موسكو
وينجو النظام من ضربه عسكريه ولكنه قد
يضطر الى تنازلات
اخرى اعتقد ان هذا الامر غير واقعي تماما
ان روسيا ملتزمه في دعم نظام دمشق وكذلك
حال ايران وحال حزب الله في الحقيقه حزب
الله خاطر بشكل كبير حيث انه ياتي بالحرب
الى لبنان من اجل منع انهيار النظام
السوري احتماليه وجود نوع من هذه النوع من
المفاوضات او التسويه امر غير محتمل وغير
مرجح اعتقد ان الرئيس تبنى نوعا
من من القرار او اتخذ قرارا له نهايه
مسدوده في الحقيقه عندما قال ان نريد ضربه
عسكريه محدده الامر لن يحقق له اي شيء
معين يجب عليه ان يعود الى التركيز الى
قضايا اخرى مهمه ليس هنالك اي طريق للمضي
قدما امام الاداره في على هذا المنهاج
بدلا غير النهايه المسدوده واعتقد ان هذا
امر مؤسف لان الولايات المتحده في رايي
بامكانها ان تلعب دورا ايجابيا في مواجهه
هذه انهاء
المعاناه وايضا توجيه
الوضع وايضا خلق ربما قع جديد في سوريا
حيث يتمكن الناس من اخذ زمام المبادره
وايضا حمايه البلد من ربما توصل وتغلغل
القاعده اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
بامكانها ان تقوم بدور
ايجابي ولكنني في نفس الوقت اعتقد ان هذه
الضربه المحدوده لن تحقق اي من هذه
الاهداف شكرا جزيلا لك سيد جيمس كفانو
مدير معهد الدراسات الدوليه بمؤسسه ايت
شكرا ايضا ضيفنا الدكتور شبلي التلحمي
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جماعه ميريلاند
بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه في امان
[موسيقى]
الله